I'm a regular guy
that got caught up in
extraordinary circumstances.
This story is as accurate as it
I couldn't make this up.
It happened to me!
Paul, is this what happened?
It's all been put in the book!
I'm a single dad raising my son,
I always brought Johnny with me
Then I came across a woman, fami
stay at home mom.
Audrey?
Let's cut there.
How does that feel, Paul?
He's the main guy, he's gonna pl
Guilty as charged, your honor!
Wow, that's weird.
Action!
Shortly after we were married...
She was trying to fleece Paul ou
(sigh)
What'd you do?
I'm getting a psychic reading.
I'm Terri Jay, I'm a pet psychic
I'm sensing that this is bigger
What!?
(shocked breath)
I said that!
That started the discoveries
Holy!
of her secret double life.
She had a secret phone
and she had secret addresses.
This is the spot!
This woman must be stopped.
Thanks!
You're welcome.
You're gonna leave me hanging?
I went and paid a visit to the F
This story, every time you turn
I'm the warrior now.
You'll find several more pebbles
Aw, I've got goose bumps!
I'm in full stealth mode!
This case haunts me!
It started off here, and it just
Beam me up, Scotty!
I'm in the Twilight Zone!
I don't know that it makes sense
No no no! This is the script now
Don't worry. It'll be great!